hello everyone welcome to the winescape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
sometimes when talking about cosmology I
will remind people that our universe
which is about 14 billion years old or
roughly order of magnitude 10 to the 10
years old right which sounds pretty old
is nevertheless pretty young in some
sense our universe is just a baby
compared to how old it will be of course
we don't know exactly how old the
universe will get but according to the
leading cosmological models that we have
right now the universe will get
infinitely old there's no reason for it
to ever end and anyway it will use up
its fuel in some finite amount of time
the Sun's shining the stars are shining
galaxies are shining but this shining
won't go on forever stars are gonna burn
up their fuel in about 10 to the 15
years so that's a hundred thousand times
the current age of the universe and then
the last black hole will evaporate away
we think roughly speaking about 10 to
the 100 years from now in other words
about a Google years from now in the
original notion of the word Google
before the search engine took it over
the idea of a number 10 to the 100 was
actually invented sort of almost as a
joke just as to stand in for a really
big number you would never actually
think to use today's guest Antonio
Padilla Tony Padilla as he's known uh
thinks otherwise and he's written a
wonderful new book called fantastic
numbers and where to find them a cosmic
Quest from zero to Infinity where he
talks about these big numbers Google and
of course it's cousin the Googleplex
which is 10 to the power of a Google but
then even way bigger numbers than that
number theorists mathematicians
theoretical computer scientists have
devised clever ways to represent these
ginormously big numbers much bigger than
you can really wrap your head around in
a very real sense as Tony will point out
as we talk but what I really like about
it is that Tony's day job is as a
cosmologist he's a theoretical
cosmologist writes similar papers to
papers that I've written he thinks about
the cosmological constant and the cosmic
microwave background and dark matter and
dark energy and things like that and so
he finds ways to relate these
ginormously big numbers to the physical
world you might think that some of these
numbers are just so big they have no
possible physical relevance and then as
soon as you say that someone is going to
find out a way to bring them down into
physical relevance and so which raises
by the way some interesting
philosophical questions so you are these
numbers even real if you could find a
number that is so big that it is
impossible to contemplate any physical
relevance of it then is that even a
potentially real thing is that is that
something we should include in our set
of numbers and that that's too
philosophical we're not going to talk
about that stuff that much but the point
is the very existence of big numbers is
not only useful to physicists but
stretches our brains in thinking about
them in fun ways and so this is gonna be
a fun conversation about exactly that
let's go
[Music]
Tony Padilla welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi Sean how you doing I'm doing
all right now you've written a wonderful
book and and we'll we'll be talking
about stuff in the book and it's about
big numbers but you're a physicist
you're not a mathematician you you you
you and I are very similar in in the
papers we've written over the years
right there's a lot of overlap there
we've cited each other
um but you use the big numbers of math
as a way of talking about the universe
which I think is great and so to get
there let's start with like some numbers
that the person on the street might
think are big but the the professional
mathematician or cosmologist would scoff
at like like 10 to the 10 right that's
that's a pretty big number what does
that mean what what do we how do we
think about exponentials and other ways
of making bigger numbers
yeah so I mean when you think of
something like 10 to the 10 obviously
that's that's 10 multiplied by itself 10
times so it's a 1 followed by 10 0. so
you see that and it clearly looks like
it like a huge number but that's kind of
quite a this idea of sort of repeated
multiplication giving you exponentiation
is just a first in a in a whole chain of
ideas that you can build in mathematics
and uh yeah it's just one one of or it's
really just the seed for something that
can grow much larger larger and
therefore can grow much bigger numbers
well the famous one of course is the
Google and then the Googleplex and
there's there's fun stories about how
that came to be
yeah so so of course at Google which
obviously most people associate with the
uh with the search engine and it spelled
differently when we talk about a number
it's
g-o-o-g-o-l right of course but what so
what is it Google it goes back to um
Edward kosner who I think those of us
who work in cosmology will know from he
has a space-time named after him which
people have used to think about the
early universe and that sort of stuff
but what kazner was actually doing was
kazner was thinking about um he was
writing a popular science book which you
know we've both done and um and he was
trying to really convey the ideas about
infinity and really how any finite
number no matter how big it might seem
to us in our sort of day-to-day lives is
actually negligible or essentially zero
compared to the infinite so he just sort
of he came up with a a big number well
what's a big number a one followed by
never mind ten zeros that you talked
about but but a hundred zeros right so
one followed by a hundred zeros now no
one's going to deny that's a big number
right by any Earthly measure that we use
and yet and he wanted a name for this
number so he consulted his nephew who
was nine years old at the time his name
was Milton Serrata and he said well can
you come up with a name for this big
number and Milton said well at Google so
it came from his nephew but then the
story didn't stop there because of
course castner wanted to go bigger and
still talk about how even bigger numbers
were sort of small compared to the
infinite and so he he's came up with a
new number which was a Googleplex which
is supposed to be loads bigger than a
Google right right so when he asked he
asked his his um his nephew Milton you
know what what would be a good um a good
definition for this so Milton said well
it should be a one followed by zeros
until you get tired
which I think for somebody like like has
there at any mathematician uh that's a
little imprecise
yeah yeah so he he went with um a more
rigorous one so so whereas a Google is a
one followed by a hundred zeros a
Googleplex
is a one followed by a Google zero so
it's a whole new level of size that
you're talking about and it this sort of
develops an idea of recursion in maths
which is which is really powerful so
from a Google Plex you can go to well
what some people call a Google duplex
which is a one followed by a Googleplex
zero and then you can go to a Google
Triplex which is a one followed by a
Google duplex series you can see every
time you do this you're going bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and uh
that's the power of math yeah no I mean
that that recursion is like basically
the secret right like you make a big
number like some process and then you do
the process again and the number becomes
way way bigger than you started yeah
recursion repetition it's it that that's
that's what really gives you the
calculational power to get to grow
numbers really really quickly
um and yeah it's the beauty of it and
maybe it's uh useful to ground us in the
real world a little bit I mean we live
in a world that is pretty big like you
know there's eight billion people on
earth almost right and but the
professional cosmologist deals with even
bigger numbers the number of galaxies or
stars in the universe but they're
they're none of them are that big
compared to with Google why don't you
give us some of like the size and scale
of the universe and compare it to these
big numbers yeah I mean especially if
you think about
um the Universe I mean various things
numbers you can pluck out is things like
you know how big is the universe how
what's the size to the sort of the
cosmological Horizon is which is as far
as we can see well that's about 10 to
the 26 meters so that's you know one
followed by 26 zeros so that's the
distance in meters to the cosmological
Horizon which is what we'd normally
think of as as our universe
other numbers big number
can think about in the context of the
universe well it probably doesn't really
get any bigger than the number of
particles that exist in the universe
yeah right and that's 10 to the 80 which
is you know one followed by 80 zeros and
that's already way smaller than it than
a Google right so Google's one followed
by 100 series and so 10 to the 80s you
know it's 20 orders of magnitude smaller
so one of the things I talk about in the
book is what what could you do if you
were a Google Heir if you had a Google
pounds right you could literally buy
every particle in the universe you know
a really inflated rate and and still
have plenty of money left over now I
might actually be misremembering this
but I thought it was 10 to the 88th
particles if we're counting photons and
and neutrinos and so forth yeah okay
that's the the that's right I mean the
typical ass may be just going on
veryonic Parts yeah so like the 10 to
the 80 protons and neutrons and stuff
like that perfectly fair but you know I
I know I have listeners they're they're
going to write in so this is
and so what that makes you think oh
let's also get on the table Avogadro's
number or like some number dealing with
Biology somehow just to to make sure
that the biologists don't have bigger
numbers than the cosmologists do oh well
now you're testing me sure because I I
stopped in violate you but I was about
20 when I was about 13 so
after college is that the one that's 10
to the 23 is that it is you got it right
and believe me I live in fear of people
asking me that too but I had to recently
look it up so yeah 6 10 and 23.
right yeah exactly and that's the number
is what's that the number of particles
in a molar gas or something like that
yeah yeah so see this this is really me
digging back to my old high school
education education is it enough
yeah there's nothing I've been working
with in my in my uh in my day jumps to
be honest but yeah of course a number of
particles in a mole of gas which is um
it's a huge number right but you know
what I think that number really shows
you know demonstrates to us is is
there is actually huge numbers lurking
right beneath our nose and it's
basically because of the you know the
hierarchy of scales that we see in
nature right so it's on the one hand
we've got like the scale that we you
know of of us you know right roughly a
typical human who's around you know
between a meter and two meters tall and
and that's a typical scale of our size
but then you compare it to the sort of
subatomic world and and all that and you
know the even all molecules and
particles and all that that's such a a
much smaller scale and that's where you
can get big numbers like avocados uh
constant just coming out of quite
mundane things it's really the
difference between you know particles
and and the world that we live in and if
the universe around us only has 10 to
the 88th particles in it and so typical
macroscopic human scale things have
Avogadro's number of particles in them
isn't there like the naive guess would
be you never need a number as big as a
Google and 10 to the 100 is bigger than
all of those no numbers
well yeah I mean I guess that's an
interesting way of looking at it but
like I said depends what you define to
be our universe right I mean so on the
one I mean this is the one thing I
always wanted to do with with these
numbers so these numbers they are in
some sense
beyond our universe right and so what I
try to do in the book is drag them into
our universe to try to get some sort of
physical personality from them which is
it it's not easily done because you're
absolutely right they don't have a
natural place in there but when you try
to bring them in then you can really
reveal some quite remarkable physics and
remarkable ideas of physics that's
that's the idea I mean it's always been
the case for me that that numbers
I mean I I I started studying maths to
University and and uh you know for me
there is there is a beauty in numbers
and there's an Elegance in numbers but
but I've always needed a little bit more
and what I've needed is that little bit
of Personality
um and that personality I think comes
from physics yeah and bringing the
physics bringing the physics into the
game so you're absolutely right how do
you drag a number like a Google or even
a googolplex into the physical world
well you have to go a little bit beyond
our universe or what we normally talk
about our universe and you have to start
to think about maybe the universe Beyond
the cosmological Horizon and imagine the
universe that maybe is much larger
and then you can start to really start
to play games with these these truly
gargantuan numbers the in the difference
between mathematics and physics as as
occupations or pastimes is a fascinating
one because I do think that people who
are neither one of those might think
that they blur together right I mean
you're pushing around equations and
you're trying to solve them but but the
motivations are really quite different
right the things that get a
mathematician really really excited are
very often not the things that get the
physicists excited
I I think that's entirely true I think
sometimes we can we can get sort of fed
up with the pedantry of our
mathematician colleagues right it's like
you know this is this you know like why
are you worrying about this detail it
doesn't matter it's not going to change
the physics right because you know you
know we have this idea of decoupling in
physics that we don't worry about little
tiny you know microscopic details
they're not going to affect what's
happening on laparoscopic scales and so
we don't need to worry about your little
pedantry it's not important in the
broader game scheme of things and I
think that's probably where the
mathematicians um and physicists differ
in in their approach and it was always I
mean I'll give you an example of what
what really was that triggered my change
in my attitude to this was was I was
doing um
uh it was it was shortly after I first
went to Union as I said I did a math
degree and I had this proof to do and I
wrote out the proof and and I had all
the arguments correct and there was no
issue with it but I got zero I got zero
for this proof and it was really
frustrating I was like why have you
given me zero and I thought you know
what's going on here and it and he the
the the the Don at the time acknowledged
that that you know the proof was correct
but he didn't like where I put the
implication signs in the in the in the
layout of the proof right they were all
on one side of the paper and he goes
well there's nothing on the other side
of the paper and I was like well this is
ridiculous right this is this is the
level of pedantry which I which it's too
much for me and I need more from my
numbers and that's where that's where I
started to look towards physics and you
tell from reading about it in the book
that this incident really scarred you
for life you remember me yeah it really
did it really did I mean I kind of got
it I mean we're looking back I kind of
got it because you know you know when
you mark exam scripts and if things
aren't laid out well it can it can be
really frustrating really but wow this
this I thought was a a pedantry too far
but yeah I mean the way that I think
about it is if if you have a billion
examples of some mathematical
construction and there's some property
that is true for all but one of them the
mathematicians really really care about
the one where it's not true and the
physicists only care about the others
where it really is true yeah that's true
although at the same time we do we do
focus on on the things about our
universe when we think about the
properties of our universe it's the
things that don't make sense that we
care about it's the things that don't
add up that we care about all of all the
wonderful things there just yeah that's
how it should be we're not going to
worry about those details but we're
drawn towards the puzzles as is
everybody I guess
so one of the things that the
mathematicians do with with this
attitude of being interested in the math
for its own sake rather than to describe
physics is they find ways either because
that's what they want to do or because
they stumble upon them in in the process
of their regular math find ways to
generate way bigger numbers than a
Google or a googolplex or a Google
duplex
Etc so why don't you why don't you tell
us just some of your favorite gigantic
numbers because there's a lot of a lot
of sort of philosophical aspects of what
these numbers mean when you get right
down to it
yeah so do you want me to tell you a
little bit about about how you generate
these really big numbers Okay cool so so
there's a really so so when you really
talk about big big numbers like the kind
of number like Graham's number which is
the largest number ever to appear in a
mathematical proof for a long time when
you're talking about numbers like that
there you can't just use our
conventional mathematical language that
people learn in school to describe them
they're just too big they're just too
big so you need to develop new ideas
right so so one of the things you can do
is you can develop this sort of there's
a um Donald knuth who believes in
Stanford is a computer scientist over
there he he developed a new notation to
sort of build very very big numbers and
it it kind of uses again this idea of
recursion and repetition so very simply
so if you think about really go back to
sort of fundamental level and you think
about well what is you know what what is
multiplication well when I save
multiplication I'm really doing repeated
addition so so three times four is three
added to itself uh four times right
that's what it is and so okay so you've
gone from from sort of addition to
multiplication using this idea of
repetition and recursion well you can go
now you can go one step up again you can
say well what is repeated multiplication
well we're still in a high school realm
now we're talking about exponentiation
so you know when you say what is three
to the four well that's three to the
power of four that's three times times
by itself four times right so
exponentiation is repeated
multiplication now at high school level
you stop at that point right that's
enough politicians don't right they
don't so they carry on and so so instead
of saying that three to the power of
four is instead of saying it like that
they'd say three Arrow four okay that's
the notation they would use
and then you go a step further so just
to be because we can't see in the audio
podcast this is like a little upward
going arrow in this notation right yeah
yeah exactly so you have a little look
with arrow so instead of saying three to
the power four you say three up with
arrow four good okay and so that just
means the same thing now you can go go a
step further you've got repeated
addition gives multiplication repeating
multiplication gives exponentiation or
what's repeated exponentiation
okay well that's called tetration right
and you can denote that with two arrows
so you have now three two arrows four
that would mean three exponentiated four
times so three to the three to the three
to three like that and you can build
like this and of course once you've got
double arrows you can have triple arrows
which are repetitions of double arrows
and you can have quadruple arrows which
are repetitions of triple R's and you
very quickly get very very big numbers
so for example let me give you an
example so so three to the power of
three is twenty seven so three out of
three is twenty seven what's three
double ro3 well that's three to the
power of 27 which I think is about 7.6
billion so already you get very big
pretty now you do more and more of these
repetitions you get really really huge
numbers and this technique allows you to
grow to very large numbers as large as
Graham's number
and the rules of the game I guess are
that we we have a finite number of
symbols to work with right so we're
trying to figure out ways to denote big
numbers without just listing all the
digits or whatever that's that's
impractical there are not enough atoms
in the universe but but we can compactly
represent some of these giant numbers
so in the example we talked about the
not you know that each new arrow in this
notation allows you to sort of grow
things much more quickly but what you
can then do is you can then start to
sort of almost uh label the arrows
themselves the number of arrows
themselves and grow the number of arrows
in this hugely sort of powerful way and
then you can keep doing that and keep
doing these these tricks and again it's
like you say it's compactifying the
notation
um that can allow you to sort of grow
very quickly and then you always put a
little label on it and then that label
then there's some idea of what what you
do at the next step what do you do when
you do the repetition and then and then
and then you can grow the labels you can
grow everything mathematicians love
having games with symbols and labels and
you know in some sense getting the right
notation is really what gives you the
mathematical power and so what is
Graham's number
so so Graham's number is this extremely
large number that was that was um
it came about uh from the mathematician
Ron Graham uh he used it in a
mathematical proof he was trying to
solve a problem in a branch of
mathematics known as as Ramsay Theory
now Ramsay Theory very Loosely it's the
idea of finding sort of order from chaos
so you have some sort of random assembly
of things and you're trying to find sort
of structure and cliques and and cut
some sort of order within that player so
for example if you think about the
houses of Parliament in the UK and
you've got a whole sort of you know
gossiping bunches shouting and it seems
very chaotic and everybody seems to be
disagreeing and it's just it it's chaos
but you might ask is there some order
within that chaos and you say well maybe
there is maybe there's a bunch of of um
trade unionists that there's a clique of
trade unionists there within that sort
of seeming chaos there is agreement and
and all that a kind of intuitively
Ramsay theory is the um is the study of
that intuitively now what Ron Graham was
doing he was looking at at a problem
involving hypercubes which are sort of
generalizations of Cubes to higher
Dimensions you know five six seven eight
nine whatever number Dimensions you
might be interested in and he was
looking for a particular a property of
these cubes and he wanted to know how
many dimensions did you have to have to
guarantee that this particular
mathematical property would would exist
it would always be guaranteed to hold
and what he showed was was that it's the
number had to be I think bigger than six
dimensions but it had it it needn't it
that the sort of upper limit was this
Graham's number which is this truly
gargantuan
number that you can't write in any
conventional way you need this fancy
mathematical tricks and notation to
write it now
for me as a physicist I did my usual
thing where I like to think about well
okay this is all fine and it's all nice
thinking about hypercubes and thinking
about you know this number and and some
wonderful maths in there and it's great
and it's lovely but but can I bring it
into the physical world
I said well most people when they think
about a number they don't think of canal
Sorrows or some fancy mathematical
recursion tricks they don't think about
that they just think of it written out
right using the standard way that we
write out numbers in our decimal
expansions that we use right that's what
people do
so I said well I suppose somebody thinks
about Graham's number what would happen
then if they tried to picture it in
their head and they quickly realized
that if you do that
then you have a bit of a problem because
Graham's number is so large
and what you must remember is that each
digit in Graham's number contains a
little bit of information sure okay
there's information stored in each one
of those digits
and so if you've got a picture Graham's
number in your head you're storing a
hell of a lot of information in your
head
and information weighs
and if information weighs then every
time you picture one of Graham's number
did Graham's numbers digits you're going
to store some information in your head
you're going to add some Mass to your
head might only be a very microscopic
amount but it will be a little bit yeah
and when you've got the whole of
Graham's number in there
well you're basically trying to cram too
much into your head and the inevitable
outcome will be that your head would
collapse into a black has this ever
happened
this I'm not aware of it ever happening
maybe it's one of those things we have
to worry about like you know they've
created a black hole at the uh at the
LHC you know right so somebody's
thinking about trades a little bit so
just to get this right
um if someone just asked you you know
how many digits in Graham's number like
there's no known answer to that right
it's not just to say the number of
digits would be some incredibly large
number yeah it'd be a huge number so so
so yeah no I don't think you could is
there a way to calculate it
it's probably of all the Graham's number
this is ironically the answer so it may
be the logarithm it's probably the log
of ground number right it doesn't help
very much it's still enormously large
yeah a bit of logarithm of ground number
so but but already
but you also what you can calculate the
thing that you can calculate is is how
much information you can contain inside
a space the size of a human head that's
something you can calculate and the
reason you know what the maximum amount
of information you can contain a size
space the size of a human head is
because you know the thing that contains
information the best and the thing that
stores information the best in the
universe is a black hole nothing stores
information better than black Oz they're
brilliant information stories and so you
just ask yourself the question how much
information can I store in a black hole
the size of it of a human head
and it's way less than Graham's number
yeah and let me so I have some deep
philosophical questions about the
existence of these numbers but I just
want to get one more number on the table
first which is tree three I love this
number can you talk a little bit about
it but I don't think I'd ever heard I'd
heard of Graham's number before but not
of tree three
yeah so so tree three is um it's so the
way I talk about it in the book is I
link it to this idea of of the game of
trees
um so so this is so very intuitively you
have a game where where you you have
seeds and you have branches and you
build trees right and there are various
rules to the games like you know you
start off with a with a single seed and
then you can start adding and then
somebody writes down a picture of a tree
with a single seed and then the next
person writes down another tree with
maybe branches and different seeds and
so on and each each time you start
drawing these trees now there's sort of
this various rules but one of the rules
is that if somebody writes down a tree
which contains a sort of a bit of a tree
that's gone before
then the game's over so what that mean
what I mean by that so so let's suppose
we're playing Sean and and you know you
draw one particular tree and then five
goes later I draw a different tree and
sort of set within my tree is a bit of
is something that looks a lot like your
tree yeah okay then I would lose okay so
the question you can ask is is how long
can this game last
right so how long could you keep going
drawing trees without any previous tree
being in it yeah yeah is the game
guaranteed to end for example is it
guaranteed to end and if so how long can
it go on for these are the kind of
questions you can ask now it turns out
the the game is always guaranteed to end
no matter you know how many different
types of seed you use right so one of
the things you can ask is is well how
many how many suppose I have one type of
seeds so let's say a black seed
right that's it then then that's all
I've got then I play the game and see
how far I can go now it turns out that
game can only last one move
okay because as soon as I draw the black
seed you've got to draw another tree and
it's got to contain my black seed in
game over there you go yeah so that
means that tree of one equals one
yeah exactly exactly so now you play the
game with two seats I was gonna ask
different types of skis so maybe a black
and a white seed right right
and okay now you can play the same game
again and
you start writing down the things that
you're allowed to do and it turns out
the game cannot last beyond three moves
okay that's the maximum there's no way
the game is lasting Beyond three moves
okay so tree of two
is three equals three okay so we our
sequence so far is one comma three comma
tree of three
exactly so so now you play the game with
three different types of seeds so let's
say you've got a black seed a white seed
and a red seed and you've you can make
trees that are combinations of these
seeds that have got branch that branches
and all sorts of fun and games right and
again there are various rules about what
you can lay down initially but but you'd
agree to those rules so we're playing
this game now Sean and
again you can ask how long can it go on
for
and you might think well okay well for
one seed it only lasts in one game one
one go for three for two seeds it lasted
three goes so maybe it's either maybe
it's gonna be like ten goes for three
scenes or 15 goes or something like that
and it's not it goes bang it just
literally goes off of one it's the most
crazy sort of jump in a sequence you
could ever imagine it goes to this
number three three which I mean we just
talked about Graham's number which is
which is too big to fit in your head
well I think tree three is too big to
fit in the universe it's it's just a
number which is it's beyond anything I
mean it dwarfs these already gargantuan
numbers it's an absolute monster
um and yeah it comes from from this
thinking about this game and and and
um
and and there's you know there's lots of
one of the things it's used for actually
one of the things that's useful for is
is proof Theory and understanding what
you can prove what you can't prove with
within a within mathematics and these
kind of tree games are a good vehicle
for that but it's interesting because
tree three you can State what it is it
is you know the largest number of games
what is exactly the definition the
largest number of moves that you could
do it's the kind of maximum length of
the of the of the game of trees with
three different seeds gotcha and I can
say those words out loud but I can't in
a Down to Earth Sense calculate the
number I mean it doesn't fit into the
universe right no it really can't fit
into the universe and this is this is
the kind of thing that this is again
where we try to bring physics into the
game right and start to say well okay
let's think about actually playing these
games right so so you know me and you
Sean we start playing this game right
and we're gonna play with three C's and
this is gonna we're really good at this
game so you know we make sure we don't
get knocked out
right and so we play this game we play
this game we play as fast as we can well
how fast can we play it we certainly
can't play a go you know a single go
faster than a plank time right because
if we which is 10 to minus 43 seconds if
we do faster than the plank time we
break space time so we're not going to
do that so that's that's
we go we're going as fast as FaceTime
will allow us right so we're doing it
like we're playing this frantic game of
drawing trees drawing trees drawing
trees drawing trees drawing trees well
you know we'd be old men long before
um
this game was over okay so maybe we you
know okay so we pass away and we replace
ourselves with some fancy AI device
which carries on play in the game like
Beyond uh beyond our um
beyond our sort of mortal lives this
game's playing so there's AI Sean and
there's AI Tony playing this game of
trees and playing and playing and
playing
and they would carry on playing beyond
the age of the solar system the sun
would die
um so who knows what's powering this
this these AI devices but suppose They
carried on maybe they're getting their
energy off the cosmic microwave
background I don't know so they carry on
playing this game they carry on playing
and they would go far beyond this sort
of you know the heat death of the
universe
and it would go even beyond that and
eventually the game would go on and on
and on and on and on and then he'd say
well but surely it's going to end at
some point right
and the problem is it never count
because one of the things we know about
the universe is that we think it's a
finite system
and in any finite system
you get something called upon career
recurrence which is where everything
comes back to where it began so for
example if you think about a pack of
cards right so if you think about a pack
of cards when you open a pack of cards
you know you normally they're all laid
out in the mat you know order of suits
and it's really nice and then somebody
starts shuffling it and they get messed
up and and so on and you play lots of
games of cards and they get regularly
messed up well if you keep randomly
shuffling the cards
eventually and it took a very long time
but eventually you'll get back to the to
all the cards lined up as they were when
you bought them it will happen Okay and
it happens after this point career
recurrence time and this is something
that's true of any finite system
and so if after universe is a finite
system which we believe it is then
that means that the Universe willing
will undergo upon career occurrence and
the time it would take for that pancreat
recurrence is not enough time for you to
finish the game of trees so the universe
reset itself I'll put on the table that
I I'm not sure that the universe is a
finite system I think it's an excellent
question that we don't quite know the
answer to but it at least is absolutely
plausible that it is so I'll go again
yeah I mean I guess I'm basing on the
idea that we're sort of you know we're
dominated by dark energy which in
documentary is going to dominate the
universe for a long period and and then
um
yes and I guess I'm I'm basing on the
ideas that the the
you know things like the city thinking
about the city universe and and the
amount of degrees of freedom Associated
right I do want to talk about that I
just want to you know point out that we
don't that we don't know which is
perfectly uh safe thing
but so I guess the question about these
numbers like Graham's number in tree
three is we can Define them
uh but do we really know what they are
if we can't calculate them what does it
mean to know what a number is what is it
oh right yeah I mean what does it mean
for it to sort of be meaningful you know
I mean I guess the difference between
what it is to be meaningful and what it
is for us to know whether it exists or
not I guess this comes back to the sort
of the idea of whether any number exists
right
which is a whole new philosophical
debate and there's you know there's
these ideas the numbers only exist that
they kind of exist outside the physical
world and and and or they're only there
to describe
um the things that are in it so there's
no such thing in some senses an
emancipated number there's only just a
number that can describe the number of
Cups of Tea I've got or or the number of
of of magic beans I have or whatever
right so so but there's all these
different ways about thinking about
whether a number exists and I don't
think there's any consensus within
within philosophers about about that and
I think that probably also applies to to
um
to to big numbers as well I mean one of
the things you can ask is is I did a
video about this quite recently and it's
a bit of a controversial video but it
was a about what's the biggest number
anybody's ever will ever think of right
right so sorry so so you can ask
yourself a question if I think sorry I
didn't say that right well you could say
what is that what is the number you know
how big a number do I have to get to
find another that nobody will ever think
of so how big do I have to go right so
and the estimate I came up with is that
if you think of a random assortment of a
73 digit number or so
random assortments of digits then
chances are nobody in the history of
humanity will will ever think of that
number it's just some kind of you know
silly trick with with you know sort of
not you know numerology a little bit and
try to think about how many numbers that
an individual person would would think
of and you think about bamford's law and
the distribution of numbers and that
sort of thing
um but but you know I think it's true
that certain numbers that are sort of
maybe not Graham's number because we've
thought about Graham's number it's been
conceived up but if you think of the
numbers that are just in and around
Graham's number that are maybe just I
don't know just somewhere around it
doesn't matter right yeah no one's ever
going to think of that number no one's
ever going to have anything ever to do
with that number not even any person but
probably no alien or anybody the
universe will definitely something
terrible is going to happen to the
universe before before that number is
ever conceived I think yeah no and and
that's what it's a little bit humbling
to think about this if you invent the
rules of the game being that you have a
finite alphabet of symbols to write
things down with and a finite number of
such symbols that you can put in your
piece of paper book or whatever and
these symbols are supposed to represent
numbers as you get out there to bigger
and bigger numbers
of smaller and smaller fraction of all
the numbers are representable even in
principle right like it's literally
impossible to even even if you just
stick to the integers
uh it's literally impossible to
denote all of these different numbers
and I'd say the flip side though is
there is a flip side to this as well
it's kind of the unreasonable
effectiveness of uh of mathematics in
our universe right so you're talking
about mathematics which seemingly isn't
in our universe right and one of the
things I've tried to do in the book is
bring into our universe and you get all
this extreme physics as a result but but
at the same time there's the question of
we have our universe
and yet maths has this uncanny ability
to describe it and there's no reason why
that should be true right it's kind of
maths is a man-made thing right maths is
well maybe that's something we could
debate but but it feels like it's a it's
a mummy creation right and yet it's
doing an amazing job about um of
describing the universe like I think
that vignette the you know the great
physicist vigna has this this lovely
idea where he thinks about um you know
so you think about a distribution of
bread amongst people and and how this
will contain the number Pi when you
think the the the the
distribution of bread in a random
community
it'll contain the number pi and at the
same time somebody can say well yeah
that and what's that number pi oh yeah
that's something to do with the radius
of a circle
the circumference of the radius of a
circle are you like well what's that got
to do with the distribution of a random
distribution of Fred it's not got
anything to do with it and
only at the same number appears and I
think this is what and it's amazing that
the universe is so mathematical and one
can ask Will it always be is it is it
guaranteed to always be a mathematical
or or is it mathematical up to a point I
mean it's it's done and math has done an
amazing job right of describing our
universe but is that something we can
rely on forever I don't know and one of
the fun things you do in the book is you
just just to connect our previous
discussion of cosmic numbers that are
pretty darn big to these wild math
numbers that are just hilariously big
let's make that the technical term
hilariously big numbers yeah uh but you
it turns out that even though there's
only 10 to the 88th particles in the
universe you can still formulate
sensible sounding physics questions that
require us to think about numbers much
bigger than that and the question that
you you dwell on a little bit is the
doppelganger question so why don't you
set that up for the audience yes so one
of the things I I wanted to think about
was um you know well I was really trying
to sort of do this thing where I tried
to make a big number like in this case a
Googleplex try to think about it in a
physical setting yeah and so you know we
talked about how the universe reaches to
10 to 26 meters uh to the cosmological
Horizon now it's not that you get to
that cosmological Horizon and there's a
big wall and and you can't pass it right
that's that's not how it goes right you
can who knows what's beyond the wall
right I mean maybe wildlings Beyond the
Wall who knows right but but so so the
universe couldn't principle be much much
larger right it's entirely possible
and so I wanted to imagine well what if
it was a Googleplex across in meters say
it doesn't really matter whether you use
meters inches Fair lungs whatever it's
not going to make much difference so you
imagine a really big universe which is
which is this big a Google Plex across
in same meters
and I thought well what would be the
consequences of such a universe and the
kind of remarkable thing is that you you
realize that doppelgangers would be kind
of an inevitability in such a universe
and why why is that well so very crudely
you can think about the sort of a human
being so let's take let's take you Sean
and let's let's think about you know the
volume of space that you occupy
and you can think about the number of
ways in which you can arrange sort of
the if you speak quite cruelly about it
we can imagine atoms arranging the atoms
in that volume but if we're more
sophisticated about it we'd say the
number of quantum states that describe
that that volume of space how many are
there and there these are we expect that
this is finite this is one of the things
that we expect
and so if that's finer there's any
finite number of ways of arranging that
that um that volume of space so one of
them would correspond to you one would
correspond to a cow one would one would
correspond to a Donald Trump I'm sorry
to say there's all these different
possibilities that you could imagine
right empty space would be another one
and um but this finite number yeah so
assuming the laws of physics don't
change if you go across the universe
which is no reason to believe that they
do
then you know I I you can imagine
sampling this the the volume of space
next to you and we say right do we have
another Sean here no we don't okay let's
go to the next volume of space
another shot no we don't find another
shot there and we keep going and we
Traverse across this magnificently large
Universe which is a Googleplex meters
across
and then we find out because the number
of possibilities that could have
described that original Sean size volume
of space
is finite and less than a googolplex in
fact a lot less than a Googleplex
you realize that if you go to Googleplex
across in the meters across in the
universe then eventually you have to
start seeing repetitions now you might
say
that someone like you Sean is quite you
know it's quite rare very special yeah
you're very special Sean right you're
very special
obviously you're quite an unusual State
tonight but obviously I would imagine
empty spaces by far the most common
thing that you're going to find right
but so the probability of finding a Sean
is very low but actually the difference
between the number of possibilities and
a Googleplex is so large
that your chances of overwhelming those
probabilities become it always becomes
implausible to think that you couldn't
encounter the doppelganger yeah and if
this is
I mean maybe even a little bit more
specifically we look around our
observable universe and we in the
observable universe conditions are
pretty similar right from place to place
and so if that just extends infinitely
far out or even super duper far out then
the big there's only five number of
things that can happen everything's
going to happen over and over again
that's basically what it comes down to I
think that's that's basically it yeah
and and so what I was doing was putting
a number on that really and so you
estimate the typical distance to your
doppelganger and it's I think the number
I have is 10 to the 10 to the 68 meters
is roughly the distance you might you
might estimate would it be weird for me
to say that doesn't seem that far
I don't think you're gonna be going
there on your holidays but the the
implication is also that every copy of
the there's also every copy of me with
every possible small variation right yes
yes exactly so this is one of the things
to talk about is it one can ask the
question well what is a Cochlear View am
I talking about something that's just
something that looks like you or or am I
being much more precise than that can I
talk about you know something that looks
like you and has the same thoughts
instantaneously and you know all the
atoms are arranged the same way all you
know all the neurons are firing in
exactly the same way in your brain and
it can really start to go right down to
the quantum State and I can demand that
it has exactly the same Quantum State
now of course to actually show that I
find you know a short to actually
measure your Quantum State exactly well
that wouldn't be very good for you sure
that would be not good at all that would
destroy you right you could attend a
plasma if I do that because I'd have to
measure the state of every single one of
your atoms and it's that's not going to
be that's not going to end well
um but at least in principle you can ask
the question
um
you know you you have some particular
Quantum State
um which I don't know precisely and I
would have to kill you to know it
precisely but it's presumably there and
there are only finite number of
possibilities until I find another one
well I think this is actually something
that is worth getting into the weeds a
little bit about because the subtleties
matter here I mean if it weren't for
quantum mechanics if it were classical
mechanics right
um and I thought that I was made up of a
set of
electrons and protons and neutrons
described by the laws of classical
mechanics then this kind of statement
would be harder to make right because
each particle is located somewhere in
space and in for just one particle in
principle I need an infinite Precision
to locate where it is
is something a little bit different
right
I think it allows you to just discretize
in some sense it's kind of the quantum
mechanics gives you gives you a
fundamental unit
um which is measured in units of plant
content of course in some sense and I
think that's what quantum mechanics does
give you that you know you can you can
literally break up phase space into into
it into sort of discrete building blocks
in a way that you can't do with
classical physics yeah I think and just
for just for the uh to be cosmologically
correct we we don't actually know the
universe is as big as 10 to the 10 to
the 68th meters across or it may be it
might be we don't know
no we don't but you can ask you you can
ask by what process might it gets so big
and I guess one way you would do that
would be
you know this idea of Eternal inflation
for example in which you can have a
universe so so we have this this one of
the things we think about our own
universe is that in very early times it
grew very big very quickly well there's
no dispute that our universe has got
quite a bit of growth and so how did it
do that and there's this process called
inflation where there's this field
which pushes the universe apart very
fast and it's known as the inflaton
field
now one of the questions that we have is
is how did that process start
and that's a bit of a puzzle
so one of the solutions to it is that
you have this this inflaton field and
what it does is it jumps about Quantum
mechanically from value to value and and
then at some point it hits this sweet
spot where it has just the right value
that it causes the universe to go crazy
and right push it push it pushes this
around you know it pushes the Universe
Part very quickly
so if that's the setup that you have
then there's absolutely no reason that
in distant parts of the universe this
inflaton field isn't doing as little
Quantum jumps and hopping around and
then occasionally hitting a sweet spot
and making that little pocket the
universe it found itself in suddenly
gargantuan and this can keep happening
you just get this inflaton doing this
little dance and then creating
gargantuan universes every so often and
if that keeps going and keeps going and
keeps going you could and it's almost
it's almost like a recursion within the
universe right because you creates a big
universe and then you have jumps within
that Universe it's create new bigger
universes and then jumps within those
universities create those new big
universes and there's kind of the
universe is doing its own recursions and
so that's how it can get to quite you
know very big numbers and so that would
be the scenario in which you could
imagine a universe this large I think
but yeah we don't know that the universe
is that big but we don't know that it
isn't either then just because there's
lots of different variations on this
theme and I want to be clear about what
the possibilities are we don't to to
make the statements about my or your
doppelgangers appearing very far away
none of this involves the Multiverse as
we usually think about it or the string
theory landscape or anything like that
it's just saying the universe is big and
you just sketched a reason why that
might be true but even without that
reason it could just be the universe is
big I think it's two things I think it's
the universe is big and it's the thing
you alluded to earlier it's quantum
mechanics at the end of the day I think
that makes those counting that you know
how we count stuff finite in some sense
it discretitizes the world in which we
live and and but there is the third
thing which is actually one of my
favorite things to think about so I'll
highlight it which is the existence of
gravity and black holes right because if
it weren't for Gravity then even in a
finite region of space we could do an
infinite number of different things in
Quantum field Theory we can do it in a
number of different things but gravity
comes along and changes the game and I
think this is this is going to matter
for your calculations
yeah so so certainly gravity sort of
provides this cutoff on on a number of
things that you can put in any finite
space because eventually it comes back
to you know if I want to sort of one of
the things you can do is if you think
about a volume of space You Can Count
how many different sort of uh bits of
information can I hide in there how many
different possibilities are there what
and then again we talked again about how
information weighs and you realize that
if you put too much information do you
allow for too many sort of hidden
possibilities
then the only option is to form a black
hole and black holes are the best hider
of all the hidden possibilities that
there is and gravity just kicks in and
makes sure that that happens and there's
nothing you can do to avoid it and um
yeah that's the that's that's the
remarkable truth and indeed If gravity
goes to if you don't have gravity is the
is the gravitational coupling goes to
zero these sort of limits that I'm
putting on the on how much you can fit
into one but the volume of space they go
they go infinite it is absolutely true
that the the the the
um the limit on the the gravity plays a
hugely important role in this
and gravity also pushes Us in the
direction that you you really put a lot
of emphasis on in the book which is the
holographic idea the idea that it's the
way that we get these countings of how
many things can happen in a region is
not by separately adding up what can
happen at each location right there
there's some Global constraints there
that make the world in some sense
have less possibilities than you might
have guessed it's really amazing when
you think about it so it's a very naive
even with gravity you might naively say
how do I count the number of ways I can
I can build a shown sized volume of
space how many different possibilities
are there and you'd say well maybe I
break up that space into the smallest
volumes that I can imagine which are in
the case of gravitational physics they
are Planck volume so 10 to the minus 35
meters across and I could say well maybe
each of those different volumes has a
certain number of possibilities it can
States it can be in and then I just add
them all up right but if you did that
you would get a massive over counting
and that's because
what gravity actually does is it forbids
loads of possibilities loads of possible
combinations it just does and actually
the the that that would be the wrong
calculation you do what it right it
doesn't store its information in the
interior of the space it seems in the
way that I've just described there where
you break the space up it's a lot of
tiny little bits it seems to store on
the edge of the face that's where the
counting is done and so when you look at
a Sean size volume of space you should
really you want to work out how many
possibilities there are you need to
break up the surface that surrounds you
into the tiny uh building blocks and
calculate how many possibilities there
are there but this is the remote I mean
I think I think the holographic
principle is I mean it started to
develop around the time I was doing my
PhD and I think it's it's mind-blowing
and fascinating and and so profound in
so many ways
um but yeah yes indeed indeed this is
using the holographic ideas to give you
the sort of the better estimates for how
many different possibilities there are
and I think that lurking in the back of
my mind and your mind here is the idea
of entropy but maybe we haven't
connected that explicitly if you want to
do that
yes yes so yes I am talking about
entropy right I talk about I was sort of
saying information but really in some
sense what I really mean is entropy well
entropy and information
so yeah so when when I say that that um
black holes are the best stories of
information what I'm really saying there
is that the best stories of entropy so
so you know ancient what is entropy
entropy is in some sense the number of
different ways you can sort of have a
you know and sort of a number of
different ways you can get the same
um macroscopic
sort of object macroscopic observables
you know from different possibilities so
I take an egg so take a typical Egg and
I look at an egg it looks like an egg
and it's got a given temperature it's
got a different size it's got to give
them pressure it's the egg that I see
right now what I don't know is where all
its precise atoms and molecules are
located it's not information I need it's
not information I need to know it's
temperature it's not information I need
to know it's an egg it's fine right so
all those all those little bits of
information which are hidden in some
sense they all contribute to the entropy
because different possibilities could
could give the same a and the number of
possibilities you count a number in
other words a number of bits of hidden
information
Allah give you the entropy
and when we talk about black holes as
being in the best stories of information
what we're really saying is is they're
the objects which have the most entropy
for their size okay and that's the thing
that's really really we're really using
here
and they it goes as the area of the
boundary and that's that's the beginning
of photography
absolutely so so one of the most
remarkable things about about black
holes perhaps the most surprising thing
you know from back in the day is that is
that when you calculate the entropy of a
black hole indeed it goes like the the
um the surface area of the of the of the
Event Horizon so
you know that's how it grows if I double
if I want to double the amount of
information stored in a black hole if I
want to double its entropy I don't
double the volume of the black hole I
have to double its surface area and
that's quite different how you normally
think of of of how you might grow
information if I were to take a dinosaur
which is not a very gravitational object
okay if I take a dinosaur if I want to
double how much information stored
inside it I would think about doubling
the volume
that's probably what you would do
but a dinosaur is is not a very
gravitational object it's not a deep a
black hole is right and and so with
black holes the game is different it
behaves differently and indeed you have
to double the surface area to double
double the amount of information it can
contain
and um and that Insight is what really
led to this idea of holography uh that
actually in some sense the the gravity
when gravity is is sometimes when you
think about the gravity in three that
say three dimensions of space it's in
some sense connected to ethereum two
Dimensions which maybe lives on the
boundary of that space
but we I I like how vague you were in
that pronunciation right there because
we don't actually know how to do that
right we don't know how to describe the
real world in terms of a complete Theory
one dimension lower that but that might
be something we're aspiring to
I think so so what we do have is is we
have so maybe we should describe what a
holographic principle really is right so
so
these ideas about black holes and how
they store information
they they've led to this um this
conjecture that
on the one hand you can have a theory of
gravity
and
let's say in in in let's say for example
in three dimensions of space but you
don't have to restrict yourself to three
dimensions but just just to be concrete
let's say we have a theory of gravity in
three dimensions of space
and that's one description of the
physics
but what the holographic conjecture
would say is there is an entirely
equivalent description of the same
physics
which has no gravity there's no
gravitational sort of you know you're
not doing Einstein's equations or
anything like that
you're just describing the theory
without gravity but in one dimension
less
and
but you describe exactly the same
physics exactly the same physical
phenomena can be described in both
languages so in some sense it's like you
know it's like when I just talk about
um a plate of Meatballs I talk about a
plate of Meatballs I say if I'm English
I'll say it's a plate of Meatballs if
I'm Spanish I'll say it's albondigas
right they're still we're both
describing the same same thing just
using different language yeah okay so I
think this is what the holographic
principle really is it's just saying
you've got physical phenomena which
you're going to use mathematics to
describe well which mathematics are you
going to use
okay I can use gravity with three
dimensions of space or I can use just
not bother with gravity and I just use
this Quantum field theory in one
dimension less and I can find a way to
describe the physics using either
language and I can get the same results
and as long as I can have a dictionary
that tells me how to go between the two
and I can do this now you're absolutely
right Sean and saying that that does
this apply to our universe well we don't
know what we do know is is that there
are examples of sort of if you like toy
universes where this conjunction the
evidence for it is absolutely compelling
so in particular you know this goes back
to goes to back to harmel De Cena
there are examples of universes that are
kind of five-dimensional they're warped
to the set of spaces
and there you can think about gravity or
maybe more precisely string theory in
these universes
and you can describe physical phenomena
that might occur in those settings and
then you can also show that there's a an
equivalent Theory which describes the
same physical phenomena which is given
by what's called n equals four super
young wheels that lives in one dimension
Less on the boundary of that space
and so we have and we have we have these
examples of where we can really show
that you don't always need gravity you
can always just do away with it and live
on one dimension less and so the cadetra
is is that true of our universe
and it seems this idea that that gravity
is somehow wants to push you towards one
less Dimension I think it's it's it's
really something deep that that may well
be true of quantum gravity that you know
when we really understand it better in
the long run right but having said all
that and the very nice version of the
sales pitch for the holographic
principle uh like you said that's not
the universe that we live in the one
where maltesena uh in anti-decider space
as we say imagine the world with a
negative cosmological constant negative
energy density in empty space but our
world as you know as well as anyone has
a positive energy density in empty space
a positive cosmological constant and
that's a both a fact that we need to
face up to and also a little bit of a
puzzle or maybe a clue depending on how
you look at it
yeah I mean people have tried to think
about these holographic ideas in a in in
even in such a setting I absolutely
agree then the the ideas are not as
robust and as clean as they are in in
anti-decity space and anti-decity space
seems to lend itself very naturally to a
holographic prescription uh in a way
that the The Sitter doesn't
um
but work is ongoing I think it's fair to
say and people I mean there's I don't
want to go into too much technical
detail but I know Ava Silverstein for
example a few years back was looking at
these you know sort of lower dimensional
examples and trying to push um
them into into from ads into the sitter
with a certain defamation of the theory
and coming up because I'm quite quite
this is this TT bar stuff that they uh
that they were playing with so there's
some nice stuff there that's been done
but I agree it's absolutely I it's not
something I'm any in any way expert on
and and it's but I know there's there's
people thinking about it but I mean
maybe we can talk about what you are
expert on which is the fact that our
energy density in our universe does seem
like a small positive number and this is
confusing to us and we would like to try
to figure this out
they get into these small numbers rather
than the large numbers that we were
talking about before yes so so what do
you talk about in the book is that small
numbers so this whole section on small
numbers and and the idea there is that
small numbers kind of portray the
unexpected they they tell you they
signify a puzzle when a small number
appears and tells you that something's
probably not making sense
and the the big thing small but if we
were looking at it for the big example
of this is is the cosmological constant
so so
one of the things we you know we we see
our universe right so so we we see that
it's that it's um a very very large
scales it's it's accelerating it's um
the university needs to be pushing
galaxies apart you know ever increasing
rates and I want to think you can ask is
well what can cause this acceleration I
mean gravity you normally think of it as
an attractive Force
but um but but so why would it why would
it cause the universe to accelerate it
would surely slow down the expansion of
the universe
but actually something can push the
universe apart at a an ever increasing
rate and that's the energy of empty
space itself the vacuum energy
and you might say well how does the how
does the universe how does the vacuum
have an energy it's just empty space how
could it possibly have energy well this
is where quantum mechanics comes in and
quantum mechanics tells you that the
actual of the vacuum is a really
exciting place it's not as furry as you
think you could you know it really is
this bubbling broth of virtual particles
that the not real particles but virtual
particles that sort of pop in and out of
existence and they can essentially endow
the vacuum with an energy
now the problem arises when you try to
calculate how much energy they give the
universe
and then you compare that to how much
energy you think there needs to be to
get the acceleration we see
and what you find is
is that the observed vacuum energy is a
factor of 10 to the minus 120
of the theoretical expectation the
amount that you calculate so it's a huge
mismatch between
what your calculations saying you should
get and what we actually see the value
that we see is far far smaller more than
a Google times smaller than what our
theoretical estimates are and the truth
is if the if the universe really did
have the huge vacuum energy there are
theoretical calculations based on
Quantum field Theory tellers it should
have
um well then it would have been crushed
out of existence within within uh you
know a moment of creation it would have
the amount of vacuum energy would have
just torn and twisted written to
Oblivion
do you know about Shannon's number have
you ever heard of that one
that's not what I know about going
Santa's number yeah well I actually
discovered it while sort of puttering
around doing research for this podcast
uh Claude Shannon of Shannon information
Theory famous asked you know how many
different games of Chess there would be
ah okay and I I forget whether it was
like total games or total strategies or
something like that but he was not able
to calculate it of course it's very hard
number to calculate but he he gave a
lower limit and it turns out to be 10 to
the 120.
okay wow which is coincidentally the
cosmological constant in in plank unit
so I think that can't be a coincidence
right maybe chess is revealing the
secrets of the universe somehow
yeah now I'm starting to pitch the
universe as a chessboard what does all
that mean right yeah that's cool each
one's a little plank uh each these
little boards are like Plank's eyes
across or something like that right I
don't know
it's a puzzle right that yeah that is
and that is probably has nothing to do
with chess we just just so everyone
knows that we're just kidding around
here but uh it's so the puzzle is that
we have a guess as to how big the energy
of the vacuum could be then we go
observe it it's much much smaller uh do
you personally have a favorite
explanation for that
yeah I mean so it's something I've
thought about a lot over the years I
mean of course I'm not gonna say it's my
favorite explanation but probably the
standard explanation is is the anthropic
one
um which says that you know the universe
is is you know if it if the vacuum
Engineers had been hadn't been tiny then
you know we never would have had
galaxies forming now the universe would
have expanded too quickly early on for
Galaxies to form or or it would have
crunched into Oblivion early on before
Galaxy's form and if galaxies don't form
and planets don't form then complex life
doesn't evolve to sort of ask questions
and record podcasts asking about about
you know how big the vacuum energy of
the universe actually is so that's the
standard anthropic story
whilst that's fine
I think you know it still behooves us to
think about
um
other ideas to try to understand where
the cosmological constant is so small I
think for me and I noticed something you
worked on as well Sean is the is this
idea that there's something very special
about the cosmological constant which
which makes it different to every other
sort of source of energy and momentum in
the universe and that's that it's
constant it does what it says on the tin
everything outside that sort of you
think about a planet or or a human being
it's a localized source of energy
momentum it drops off you know maybe
both in time and space potentially
and that's not true of vacuum energy it
it at least it's a constant right it it
it's it's sort of at least the Baseline
guy it's it it's it's it's constant and
so that's what sets it apart I think and
so when we think about what we might do
to address this this strange question
about why we don't see this huge vacuum
energy maybe we need to look at gravity
on the scale that it's reacting to these
constant sources okay so we need to look
so so if we think about this what this
means is is that we need to look at
gravity not on the local scale but on a
global scale where we're really most
sensitive to that constant source and so
one of the things that that I've worked
on and I know you have too is is to try
to think about global modifications of
Einstein's theory yeah so what that
means is that you're you're only
changing the theory on the scale of the
whole universe so it's only the the
supposed the longest wavelength modes of
the theory that when the theory reaches
out to the very very far distances that
you start to see changes right the
really literally the furthest distances
you can imagine any local physics like
what happens in the solar system well
that's got nothing to do with vacuum
energy anyway that's just the physics of
the solar system that obeys the rules of
the idea would be that ablates the rules
of general relativity and does all the
wonderful things general relativity does
but if you but what you could think
about is modifying the theory on the
global scale so really just for for so
oh so it reacts to constant sources
slightly differently
and then what you can say is well it's
fine let's say the vacuum energy is
large
it's large it just is large but my
theory of gravity reacts to constant
sources slightly differently to how it
does in in general relativity
and so I can somehow screen away this
large large vacuum energy and just get
the amount of acceleration that I see
now it's a tricky game you've got to
come up with a consistent theory that
does this that's consistent with quantum
mechanics and consists of Relativity and
all of that but that's something that
we've been trying to develop in recent
years
um through this sequestering proposal
yeah and I think this I mean it's a
great little insight for the people out
there who don't do science for a living
about healthy radical physics gets done
you know you have some puzzle you're
trying to understand then so you in
words or pictures conjecture an idea but
then the hard work is turning that into
equations right and I guess just so
people know correct me if I'm wrong here
about how you think about this
ordinary general relativity or other
theories of gravity we would write down
what they care about is the amount of
energy at each point and that's what
matters but you're imagining changing it
so that what matters is not just how
much energy there is at each point but
how it's distributed like if it's
constant versus if it's lumpy and then
that's a kind of a radical imagination
of of how to change gravity
yeah yeah kind of in a way that's one
way of thinking about it I think what
I'm saying is is that is that in some
sense you've got like a filter
so you've got the sources of energy
momentum and there's a filter but how
that Filter Works is sensitive to the
properties of the source so so this if
this source is a planet the filter
doesn't filter it's at all it just lets
it through it's a high pass filter
yeah exactly like a high possibility
exactly but if but if the source is
constant the filter shuts it down that's
the idea so so there's a there's
something in the in the theory which
which sort of you know
is acting like uh you know this cutoff
like this filter that's saying when you
may pass you may not pass but doing that
in a consistent way that that's
consistent with the sort of underlying
principles of general relativity it's
consistent with quantum mechanics it's
not easy you know one of the things that
I found about you know a career thinking
about gravity and trying to mess around
with Einstein's theory is that you mess
with Einstein's theory at your perilous
and not unleash all manner of beasts and
horrible creatures and and and and of
course all sorts of problems
um
instabilities you know new new particles
appearing that we don't see in nature
there's all sorts of problems that you
can arise but one of the things you can
do but but by focusing on those changes
only
on the global scale so only on space
time as a whole then you can actually
sort of evade a lot of these problems
well you know since we've reached the
hour-long uh moment of the podcast we're
allowed to let our hair down a little
bit and and get a little even crazier
than we than we've been getting so I
wanted to take it back to this finite
versus infinite question uh because
secretly there's a relationship to the
cosmological constant you know we you
talked about holography and the
information in the black hole and we
talked about there's a cosmological
constant that is accelerating the
universe apart but that's why implicitly
you said at the beginning of the podcast
that there's reason to believe the in
the universe has a finite set of
information in it right because there's
a horizon around us with a finite
entropy and maybe you could explain what
I just said in in more easily digestible
terms
yes so so so so
of course the we have this if we let's
say we somehow some there's some Theory
somewhere which solves the puzzle of why
the vacuum energy isn't isn't large so
it's just some small number
um so the vacuum the the energy density
of the universe is very low but it's
positive and it's causing the universe
to accelerate very gently
now what that means is is that we live
in what's called a the city universe
and we're surrounded by this they said
Horizon this cosmological Horizon this
decision Horizon in that case it would
be and when you start trying to think
about how many
um different ways there are to arrange
um sort of that Universe the quantum
states of that Universe if you think
about the entropy of that Universe it's
again this this weird property of
gravity that always projects everything
onto this surface area that surrounds
and in this case it's this the sitter
Horizon and that does sitter Horizon
that surround this shroud that surrounds
our universe that surrounds each and
every one of us individually is um
has has a finite area
if the vacuum energy of the universe is
is small and positive
um and yeah so so so so that's where
that's where I came back to these ideas
about
um you know the universe having a a pine
career recurrence such a universe would
have upon career occurrence because it
would you would think of it as a finite
system and I think one of the things
there's not even a question this is I'm
just going to set that out there because
I think people are not thinking about it
enough is that
a universe that has a finite number of
states a funny number of degrees of
freedom and it's in its theoretical
description that's a a universe that is
not described by Quantum field Theory
right which is what we always use to
describe things Quantum field theory has
an infinite number of things going on
and I don't think we've adapted I don't
think we've digested that shift quite as
much as we should have
I mean I think that's because you you
have to bring an interplay between
between you have to bring gravity into
the game and of course then then we're
talking about quantum gravity we don't
really know what quantum gravity is yeah
of course as you know as you remove
gravity as you decouple gravity all
these entropies that we're counting so
if I count what the entropy of the
sitter space would be as I take as a d
call for Gravity it goes infinite if I
calculate the entropy of a black hole
it's ID couple grams it goes all these
numbers go infinite because basically
the the entropy
um is the area divided by by Newton's
constant and as new as constant goes to
zero all these entropies go diverge so
I'll I'll give you a chance to I'll ask
a very simple question to end the
podcast uh but you can decide how at
what length you want to answer it
is the universe is reality infinite or
finite
I think it's finite
okay all right I just I just I I just uh
it's complete Prejudice I have no
accessories for knowing this I I just
part of me feels that there's there's no
room for Infinity in nature I don't know
that's a complete I mean there's
probably loads of examples everyone's
gonna get really upset at least saying
this now but I intuitively I just feel
like the idea of a of a universe which
is Compact and and you know it's
basically compared it is it seems much
more elegant to me than having to meddle
with him with the with the infinite
world that's not to say that the
infinite World Isn't mathematically it's
in itself
wonderfully interesting and something
you can think about and and and but do
we really need cantor's sort of you know
infinite Heavens to describe our
universe I don't know maybe we do yeah
my pure prejudice is that that we
probably don't I mean I ask because I I
myself don't really know I I don't even
have a Prejudice there you know on the
one hand I feel the worries about
Infinity like the mathematics of
infinity gets tricky and maybe it's just
because there isn't any real Infinity in
in the physical description of reality
but on the other hand you know Infinity
is a nice number
in a way that 10 to the 120 isn't right
you know the if the universe is finite
then there's some specific size that it
has and who ordered that I'm not really
sure well no I think I think but then
you can straight back which Infinity is
it Sean that's the next question you
have to ask right so yeah is Alex zero
is alif what is it what is it that is
you know there's there's a if the story
doesn't end with infinity you've still
got those same questions so if we keep
ourselves in the finite realm then then
things feel a little bit I just feel a
bit Cozier all right let's feel cozy I
think that's a good way to wrap up
feeling like we're cozying a finite
little universe that we live in so Tony
Padilla thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thanks Sean
[Music]